with a loss in Edmonton on Monday last night
in Vancouver losing in overtime they'll be in
Calgary Saturday night Alex wiberg Jaden
Schwarz back for wiberg 10 if knocking on
the door and barov had none of that come back
nice pass here going across able to get that
P doson Now Matt barzel one more time he'll
take it in deal it back for Noah Dobson on
the outskirts Nelson one more time to the goal
line Horvat out in front they score Anders Lee
their Captain who's been in a scoring trout gets
the power play goal and the Islanders break the
ice you're going to see harvette go down to the
goal line Anders Lee just uses his backside to
hold off dlin stick on the ice and all Horvat
has to do here is hit him right on the tape
which he does and it's pass grar but a good job
by Anders Lee using his backside to create that
Scott Mayfield in the Box delay of game Muckle
shoe Casino power play number one for the Kraken
done to the line Yamamoto Schwarz denied by barl
the locates the buck out of the corner bumper slot
Schwarz Yamamoto now bers they'll look over the
coverage deal it back for dun B downhill with
a shot he scores an absolute Bullet by Maddie
bers on the power play and the Kraken have tied
it he has a bit more time dun slides over Matty's
going downhill pulock tries to be in the lane to
block this shot he taking away actually the
pass to Yamamoto again so they learned from
the first time Matty went through stick to the
inside gives up the outside right there over the
blocker side of bar llama but what a read There
by Matty stick in the lane York Strand now out
of the corner wenberg and bork strand little
give and go good play by Ryan pulock dogging
the puck York Strand out in front they score
that's hcky baby Alex swenberg has goals and
backto back games it's a power play goal again
in the Kraken a two to one lead on this one good
battle down below the goal line borst picks it
up great feed pelic is right there as well you
thought that Bor might even have time to take
that out himself but he threads the needle over
to windberg gets that puck just elevated enough
before the glove hand can get over and John you
said that's backto back game beautiful ation last
night as he went back to Vancouver for the first
time their former Captain he's centering this line
it's broken up on the gallop matd baners powers
in kicked out by varlamov spinning off Simon
holmstrom bers feathers a pass through Center
to relieve pressure a quick up barzel has the puck
to the slot cikas scores Casey cus right through
the slot beautiful pass by Matt barel 535 left
to go in the second period tied at two Schultz
the defenseman goes to change forward's going
through cikas right up nice feed by barzel was
a penalty on the play as well going through
nice backand through the five hole move for
cikas but got put in a tough spot there Puck
didn't go all the way out you go for a change
that gets sent right up right through the goal
mouth Corvette barcel gourd's out of the box
gour great stick check and here he comes yny
gourd with a shot fought off the rebound over
skated by gour as varl fourth power play for the
Islanders they go to work barcel no ad doson will
CM it down he'll get it back from barzel heavy
shot scores no ad doson from downtown 8 seconds
into the power play and the young defenseman
has given the Islanders a one-goal lead Face
Off you get it back barzal up top it's going
to go back over to barzal but right back Dobson
heavy shot there's the screen standing right
out in front and a perfectly placed shot get
a good look here of what grow is looking
through and at the last second and that
puck goes past got Paul M standing right out
in front wasting no time ell tolven in another
opportunity to make a play tolvanen right out
in front and pinballs off Schwarz Schwarz out
of the corner Yamamoto scores Kyler Yamamoto to
the roof power play goal the Kraken up tied it
Schwarz toven in they're trying to go around
hit that back post it just misses Yamamoto finds
the spot here pulls it to the backand nice feed
here out to Yamamoto forehand backhand and into
the back of the net the power plays Red Hot for
Seattle cut off by dun jailbreak Seattle done with
gourd and never got through over skated by Schwarz
open Ice Bo Horvat har he comes Horvat bears in
on guow stopped by guau Schultz Mano Amano with
barlam off and paromov makes it look [Applause]
easy Schultz coming in trying to go
backhand forehand just Elevate that
puck up quickly but barl able to read
the play Matt barzel the former Seattle
Thunderbird with tremendous skills
swoops in and is thwarted by Philip
Gau you're right John tremendous skill here see
him head up the hole way stick Kaling trying to
make a quick move to the backhand side the grow
says no nty bers in the two hole for the Kraken
the reigning Rookie of the Year picks up the
puck let's see if he can bring the house down
no shut down by [Music] barov and he held
that glove save for a minute there mattity
with the slow approach pulls the puck in
tries to beat him on the glove side and
Bo Horvat who scored last night in his return
to Vancouver a stutter step and a oh bll hbat
gives the Islanders the lead in the shootout
well he have the the Breakaway opportunity
in overtime this time you don't have back
pressure he gets to slow up a little bit
there go quickly with that forand shot right up
over the blocker it's up to the Maestro Oliver
borran he
scores taking his time through barov looking
to get Jared mccan does he have the magic
stick no barlam off again holding his
ground sudden death now the fourth round
of shootout and going down the right
side trying to go back the other way
across the Grain on the glove side but
Bama's made a couple of good glove safe
so hard far here in the shootout the
veteran Kyle pal Mar stopped again by
grow Noah doson with a goal tonight
slowly in on guau that's all that's
crocken hockey baby the crocken win the shootout